Je comprends que vous aimeriez que j'entende vos
aveux est-il possible que je connaisse
une femme au sens biblique
parlons-nous de rapports sexuels ce
thérapeute a suggéré que je pourrais travailler avec un
spécialiste du sexe non c'est Cheryl
nous parlerons pour un  pendant et puis quand
tu seras prêt, nous arrêterons de faire
des exercices de conscience corporelle quels exercices de conscience corporelle
tu vas commencer à écouter
les signaux de ton corps de cette façon
tu pourras avoir un certain contrôle oh
ouais
dis moi quelque chose à propos  toi-même
je suis une personne très privée j'ai une vie privée
cette thérapie parle de toi imagine
toi comme un garçon de six ans tu
lui reproches d'être confortable
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'elle aime Cheryl elle est la personne la plus
merveilleuse de la
planète  les gens s'attachent les
uns aux autres tu peux laisser tomber l'amour et l'
attirance ou tu peux rendre les choses
compliquées peut-être que c'est une mauvaise idée je
pense que tu as fait une bonne chose
[Musique]
Oh